this is the story of a fictional future
that could become all too real you have
gigantic death rates in the high season
you'll have almost all the kids having
an incredible malaria fever it's the
story of a horrific epidemic perpetrated
by the dissolution delay under continent
reeling from 20 million new malaria
cases suddenly maybe 10% of the entire
population is ill at one time society
breaks down
I
millions of pounds have been spent in
Cambodia to stop the drug-resistant
malaria spreading but now with the fear
that it may not have worked the
researchers say it is a race against
time in 2016 a new strain of malaria was
spreading across Southeast Asia drug
treatments that were usually highly
effective against the disease suddenly
had little impact it will take at least
ten years before other effective
medicines may become
our vest anti-malaria drugs for failing
at one of the world's leading research
centres scientists try to understand why
these are the transmission stages of
malaria this is the initial stages of
the parasite infecting the mosquito that
leads to augment transmission attention
focused on what was happening to the
microscopic parasites that are the
source of malaria when a mosquito feeds
on human blood carrying the parasite the
insect gets infected and passes it on
when it bites its next victim the most
effective drug treatments for malaria
had always worked by killing the
parasites in the patient's blood now
some of those parasites were fighting
back mutating to outwit their attackers
resistance builds in a number of ways a
malaria patient may have a hundred
billion parasites in their body and
through random mutations it only takes
one of those parasites to have some kind
of selective advantage that one parasite
is then free to grow and colonize the
whole human all of the malaria parasites
from the mutated line are then free to
transmit to mosquitoes and be passed
other people so that drives the
resistance into the population and it
spreads further it's really sort of
Darwinian evolution in inaction the
speed at which the parasites were
evolving made it difficult for
scientists to defeat the drug-resistant
strain of the disease fears grew for the
continent that was most dependent on the
failing drugs
the resistant parasites are either
in-law sceetos or they're in people no
mosquitoes don't fly very far they fly
maximum of about a kilometer the people
fly thousands of miles so the obvious
concern is somebody gets malaria and
Southeast Asia hops on a plane lands in
Burkina Faso or Central African Republic
and spreads resistance
just thirty kilometers out of Burkina
Faso's capital and you into a zone with
a very high incidence in Ghana's capital
the eight children first phase just a
higher treatment failure rate people
start to come back more frequently after
having treatment and just start to see
slowly an increase in malaria population
there was a swift response to the crisis
from governments and aid agencies from
the rich world and from one of the
richest men in the world
I was admitted yesterday in the morning
extraordinarily serious condition Bill
Gates and his wife Melinda had promoted
and funded efforts to eradicate malaria
since the early 2000s
it's one of the diseases that the
foundation is putting a lot of resources
into there's a lot of work still to be
done the world needs more attention to
this disease annual global expenditure
towards this goal was two point seven
billion dollars before the drugs stopped
working
malaria is a very tough disease to fight
and the goal of the malaria community is
to control it better in most areas
bring the deaths down and pick some
areas to actually do eradication in both
cases whether it's control or
eradication you need a variety of tools
in 2018 the most widely used tools for
Disease Control were vaccines and drugs
but not for malaria the drugs didn't
work and no vaccine trials had offered a
definitive solution either at this point
for the best thing that we are taking
forward this is what we have seen in
previous trials and we expect this to be
the results from this trial but in
future trials we do expect to develop a
second-generation vaccine which we hope
will have higher efficacy the best
malaria vaccine on the market had at
that time an effectiveness of barely 50%
the need for other solutions was
becoming ever more urgent
the following year the epidemic spread
further across Africa
loads of people come in get ill very
quickly and this overwhelms health
services like dominos bang bang bang
I'll have almost all the kids having an
incredible malaria fever and we know
that that drops agricultural
productivity it drops kids going to
school
almost everything we were seen in Africa
that's positive that Africa's on its way
to becoming self-sufficient that would
be set back quite dramatically the
debilitating disease was costing African
states over 12 billion dollars a year in
lost productivity with millions sick
their health systems began to buckle
suddenly maybe 10% of the entire
population is ill at one time the whole
that society breaks down
by 2020
the desperate need to stifle the
epidemic was inspiring innovative
approaches people have had a go for
decades now with huge amounts of funding
lots of different things being tried and
we just think that our approach maybe
it's not a magic bullet but our approach
combined with others we think we could
make a huge impact
some scientists decided to play
evolution at its own game they focused
on the weaker sex
we actually genetically engineer males
males don't bite and these males can't
reproduce so these males go out they act
like normal mosquitoes they mate with
females but those females instead of
laying a hundred or 500 eggs in their
lifetime which all survive they don't
survive the offspring die and if you can
do that over a period of time you'll
reduce the population down so low that
actually you reduce the risk of disease
the way that sterile males are produced
is we will inject eggs with two genes
the first gene is a self-limiting gene
which means that it's offspring will die
the second gene is a color marker if you
look at that mosquito under a special
light it's got a red color when our
males mate with females every single one
of the offspring will inherit our gene
which means they'll die but they'll also
inherit this color marker it's like a
track and trace this novel approach had
already been tested outside the lab in
2014 genetically engineered males were
released in the Cayman Islands to fight
another deadly disease carried by
mosquitoes dengue fever in just six
months the species that carried dengue
fell in number by 90% people think that
this system is restricted to to dengue
fever or to certain types mosquito is
absolutely not
in 2021 the genetic engineers began to
release specially doctored males in
Africa to help tackle the malaria
epidemic but neutralizing an entire
population of mosquitoes was a slow
process and the epidemic was claiming
ever more victims
in a remote corner of the West African
Republic of Mali things were changing
what Messiah decided to make a can he
walked a man can walk in there but this
community had been shielded from the
worst of the outbreak by a new vaccine
that rewrote the rules control apologize
immediately man in Sao effectively what
the community it challenged the accepted
definition of immunization to protect
the person who receives the dose instead
this new type of vaccine would protect
everybody else the producer Watson said
the blue kala transmission duple it is
the vaccine were an trainee la
prediction the nante call the music one
don't pick a lock pepsin he won't
brother
mm time loop arise it it would see LAN
taeho
even if a person is carrying the malaria
parasite his vaccination will prevent
the disease being passed to his family
or neighbors the example of what London
community don't have a deal to same
remind eliminates and apologies
health workers here weren't taking any
chances
they knew the danger of relying on a
single solution for proving the medical
efficacy enforcement past a per day they
say memory a medicament curative
controlling value and as a test design
let me become my thickest controller
value only is attested to Lutheranism
Ali dongle a population comprised real
mantilla Wanda Warren vaccine in food
eaten it's time we still have
in 2015 the time and the techniques to
ensure malaria can be eliminated
not escalated any strategy control or
eradication it'll have Diagnostics
it'll have drugs it'll have bed nets
it'll have insecticides where we're
going out and reducing the number of
mosquitoes there it may have a vaccine
as well all these tools are being
explored in the race against malaria
every tool is vital to counter the
disease today and to shape a better
future for Africa and the world if the
drugs stopped working malaria is the
most important parasitic disease of
humans it kills more than 2,000 people
every day it's an enormous threat and it
would be devastating for the developing
world to see this problem which we had
been getting on top of go out of control
again
you